the debate over school reopening centers
around
vaccines and safety for insight into the
medical issues involved in this debate
will bring in infectious disease expert
and johns hopkins scholar
dr amish adulja dr adolja thank you so
much for being here today
as you know cdc director rochelle
walinski
this week said that the data is pointing
to
the fact that not every teacher needs to
be vaccinated in order for schools to
begin
in-person learning that was walked back
by the white house just a day later
saying that
the doctor was speaking in her personal
capacity i want folks to see
the tweet that you put up in response to
that you wrote quote the biden
administration should stand by the
science that their cdc director based
her comments on
politicians and their spokespeople
trying to undermine her
intellect and analysis by saying it was
in her personal capacity is disingenuous
and wrong so doctor what would you say
parents
should take away from this less than
clear message coming
from the administration what i think
parents should think about is
looking at the data that we're seeing
from schools that have opened all around
the country
and all around the world and trying to
understand is a school
a focus for transmission the educational
component of it not the sports not the
extracurricular activities
and i do think that the data does show
that schools can be open safely
with certain safeguards in place with
capacity restrictions and social
distancing
and it's important for vulnerable
teachers those that are falling in the
high risk groups to be vaccinated but it
shouldn't be a prerequisite to open
schools indeed we've had with open
schools in parts of the country
without teachers being vaccinated so i
don't want vaccinations to become an
obstacle to opening schools because
we know that children are suffering when
schools are closed we know that there's
data that shows that this can be done
safely
and now the current cdc director and the
cdc director before her
both really stated that this can be done
safely so i think that we need to really
make this a priority
schools should be the first things to
open and the last things to close that's
what
people like dr fauci dr wolinski dr
redfield have said
that this is this should be the norm to
have schools open
during this pandemic based on the
epidemiology based on the science
how much does this type of disagreement
that's happening of schools
actually opening up in person does it
slow it down dramatically or is it just
an insignificant blip i i do think we're
going to start to see significant delays
in opening schools
schools that are already open i think
will stay open but i i see just
in general now the rhetoric is changing
a little bit especially with
the way that the teachers unions have
been looking at vaccination as their as
their major
uh factor to go to go back to schools
we're seeing
this happen in major cities so i do
think that there's probably going to be
a delay but i wish
the administration would follow what the
cdc director is saying
and not try and discount it as something
that's in her personal capacity because
i actually trust her personal capacity
better than most people's personal
capacity that's exactly why she is cdc
director because her analysis and her
personal capacity as an infectious
disease physician
is spot on based on the science so i
think we should move forward and i would
like to see that the biden
administration follow through on opening
schools
within the first hundred days as they've
stated i think this is doable and it
needs to be done
and as we are seeing all of this unfold
we are also seeing an increasing number
of variants that are coming into this
country i want to put up
some of the information on that so folks
can take a look here
you have the uk variant cases coming in
you have two from brazil
south africa uh and then we have the
total number of cases
um in the united states right now more
than 26 million
so my question to you is how concerned
should people be about this variant
what are the dangers and distinctions
here that folks should keep in mind
so these variants likely have the
ability to transmit more efficiently
that means that we have to be better
at wearing our face coverings washing
our hands avoided crowded and
congregated places
it doesn't transmit any differently just
more efficiently and we don't think that
it's more deadly
some of the variants including the south
african and brazilian variants may
decrease the efficacy of our vaccines
but not for severe disease so if you
look at johnson johnson and the novovax
vaccines
that did trials in south africa the
their ability to block
serious illness hospitalization and
death was really undeterred by this
variant you still got infected but you
weren't getting the severe consequences
and that's the important message
that our vaccines are the solution to
these variants and the fact that these
variants are here in the united states
and spreading means that we have to move
forward with vaccination with no speed
limit we basically have to get vaccine
into
people's arms as quickly as possible and
that's going to be the way we move
forward
dr adalja we appreciate your expertise
today thank you
thank you